-You are known as a comedy fan.
I would also say you're known
as a very funny comedian,
as well, in your own right.
I would say --Who is --
Who do you think the comedian
equivalent of you is?
Who's at good at basketball
as a comedian as you --
Is it Sandler? Is that the best
we have to offer?
-I mean, I would take that
in a heartbeat.
He's also a good
basketball player.
-That's what I mean.
So he has to be a comedian
who's as good at basketball
as you, a basketball player,
are at comedy.
-Wow. Okay, I'll take that.
I like that. Yeah.
I'll take it. Thank you.
-But I was seeing on Twitter
there was --
Somebody showed up
at a Nets' press conference
and asked Kevin Durant
some questions,
and it turned out
it was David Letterman.
-Yeah, I was --
I was walking the hall --
Media Day is just crazy.
Everybody's going everywhere.
I was walking the hallway to go
to one of my next stations,
and this guy turns the corner.
I kind of look up. I don't even
see his face or his profile.
He's just kind of walking
ahead of me.
I'm like, "Boy, that looks
like David Letterman."
But he has, like,
a T-shirt and jeans on,
and he's walking by himself in
the hallways of Barclays Center.
I'm like, "There's no way
that's David Letterman."
So I go about my business. I get
to the press-conference thing.
One of the reporters is like,
"Did you see David Letterman?"
I was like, "Why?
Why is David Letterman here?"
And then it turns out
he, you know, interviewed K.D.
a little bit.
-And were you --
were you bummed,
one, that no one got you?
I would feel like somebody
should have been smart enough
to go get Blake Griffin
if David Letterman was around.
-Yeah, honestly, it's been
a point of contention
with the team.
Yeah, I would have loved
to have met him,
but I'm glad K.D.
got that moment.
That was pretty cool.
-You had another moment
with the dearly departed
Norm Macdonald,
who you actually got to know
over the years.
-I did. I did.
He -- He surprised me
at a press conference.
I did -- He had a show on
Comedy Central my rookie year,
so I did a part of his show,
and then I went to go see him
do stand-up several times.
And he came to my charity event
one year, and --
Funniest guy ever.
-Funniest guy ever.
And then this --
I had not seen this,
but somebody posted it online,
I think after --
And because David Letterman went
to this press conference.
But this is right after --
This was you giving
a press conference
having won Rookie of the Year.
-Yes.
-And you did not know
that Norm was in the press pit.
-I didn't.
I didn't know he was --
Maybe I saw him,
but I didn't think
he was gonna ask a question.
There was just people there.
He was basically
in the audience.
He wasn't even in the press row.
-It really is a perfect
Norm Macdonald joke...
-Yeah.
-...to ask the reigning
Rookie of the Year...
Let's take a look.
-It's a question from --
from Blake's good friend Norm.
[ Laughter ]
Blake, it's fun watching you
this year. Wasn't it cool?
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
-And I was wondering.
There's kind of a curse
with Rookie of the Year.
Nobody's ever repeated it.
-Hmm. I didn't think about that.
Well, I'll try as hard
as I can next year, but...
-All right, man.
-I don't know. I don't know.
-So good.
-It's perfect.
It's a perfect joke
that has been there
for the taking forever.
Every time -- Ever since a sport
had Rookie of the Year.
But what a nice moment.
-He was great, man.
Like, when I met him,
I was like --
I was so excited to meet him,
and then, you know,
he does the thing
where he starts talking,
and you're like,
"Where are we going with this?"
-Yeah.
-And then he just gets --
He always finds it somehow.
He always finds it.
And, like, seeing that in person
was like --
It was incredible for me.
-Yeah. It was really nice.
It is fun to watch
the clip, too,
and watch the people around also
realize that's Norm Macdonald.
-And then some people, like --
He didn't get
that big of a laugh.
-Right.
-That's a really good joke.
I think people
were so thrown off --
That's the perfect
Norm Macdonald...
-Perfect. Absolutely. Perfect
execution, perfect joke.
Last time we talked,
we talked about your podcast,
"The Pursuit of Healthiness."
-Yes.
-You just did a second season.
Are you still enjoying that?
-I am. I am.
It's really fun to, like, have
these conversations with people
who are leading their fields
in health and wellness,
and I've got to talk
to some really,
really interesting people,
and I love that stuff,
so it's been a blast for me.
-Do you find
when you're doing it
that it goes faster
than you think it's going to go
when you're having
the conversations?
-After a while, yes.
At first, I was so nervous,
I was like --
I don't want to, like,
bore them.
I don't want to do the thing
where I can't think
of the next question.
So I was, like, constantly --
They'd be answering.
I'd constantly be, like,
looking at my sheet,
but also trying to make
eye contact at the same time.
But, like, yeah,
as I did more and more,
like, the conversation
would just flow more naturally,
and it was a little bit easier.
It's not easy
interviewing people,
but I have a blast doing it.
-That's great.
Well, congrats on that.
Best of luck
in the upcoming season.
It's really nice
to have you here in person.
-Thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
-You guys,
that's Blake Griffin.
His podcast,
"The Pursuit of Healthiness,"
is available exclusively
on Audible.
The NBA's 75th anniversary
season tips off on Tuesday,
October 19th,
with the Brooklyn Nets
facing the defending champs,
the Milwaukee Bucks.